in a transfer of power Iran spiritual
leader the Ayatollah Khomeini has
bestowed the presidential mandate to
rouhani both men are Islamic clerics but
the new president is regarded as a
moderate and a pragmatist as he took
office rouhani again pledged moderation
he vowed to avoid the abyss of extremism
and save Iran's economy call me that has
raised many Iranians hopes that the new
leader will be able to turn things
around and says odom as wrong as a
citizen I have rouhani will ensure
economic security create jobs and paved
the way for more foreign investment in
Iran without a Thomas the Iranian media
have been heralding the end of the
Ahmadinejad era during his two terms
Iran became more isolated from the world
the UN the US and the EU imposed
sanctions over the country's nuclear
program Mahmoud Ahmadinejad's presidency
is now over but it is Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei who wields supreme power in
Iran the hardline claire's will continue
to have the final say on iran's foreign
policy and the country's nuclear program
yes long you know